i suspect that you might already be
familiar
with the term mixture it really does
mean what you think it means
if you take two or more substances and
you were to mix them together
you are dealing with a mixture and it
could be a solid
a liquid or a gas now there's
fundamentally two different
types of mixtures there's heterogeneous
mixtures
and hetero you're going to see that
prefix a lot means
different so heterogeneous
this is referring to mixtures that if
you look at it from
a macro point of view i'll do a
heterogeneous
liquid mixture and what i often think of
here at the extreme form is where with
my naked eye i could see that
different parts of the mixtures have
different concentrations of the
different
things that have been mixed up one
example i often think of is chocolate
milk that's not well
mixed at the top you're going to see
these clumps and depending where you are
in the milk you can actually see it with
your eye
that you you don't have consistent
concentrations of the different
substances
the properties of the mixtures are
different depending on what part of the
mixture
you look at now you can imagine if
there's heterogeneous mixtures the
opposite would be
homogeneous mixtures those would be
mixtures that when you look at it from a
macro point of view
it looks consistent any point of the
mixture
homogeneous
mixtures and homogeneous mixtures
there's another term for it which you
have probably heard
they're also known as solutions
and as i mentioned when we talk about
mixtures we could be talking about solid
liquid or gas
oftentimes in our head we think liquid
immediately but could be solid liquid or
gas
and so the same thing is true for
solutions you could have solid liquids
or
gases and an example of a
solid solution would be say a
metal alloy where at the
macro level its color how well does it
conduct electricity
how malleable is it how hard is it
it looks like the properties are uniform
throughout the alloy
if i have some type of metal alloy if i
were to just look at it
like this if i were to look at say
bronze well from my point of view it has
the
same properties throughout the bronze i
should probably do bronze in a more
bronze color right over here but if you
were to look at it
with a very sensitive microscope or
based on the models that we now know
what is going on
in that metal in that alloy what's
happening is you actually have a
mixture of metals
but it is a homogeneous mixture of
metals because at a macro level you
can't really see the differences
now at a micro level you can because
there are different metals
mixed in together in this alloy
now as you can imagine you also have
liquid
solutions and in chemistry these are the
ones that will often deal most we will
also deal with solid and gas
solutions as well and when i think of a
homogeneous liquid mixture
or a liquid solution the one that comes
to mind for me and but we'll see a lot
of these in our journey through
chemistry
is salt water salt
water salt water has sodium chloride
dissolved in water and if you were to go
to the ocean
and if you were to just look at the salt
water or if you were to measure its
properties even in a lab
you would see that the properties
throughout the salt water
seem to be uniform at a macro level it
appears to be
homogeneous it appears to be uniform but
if you were to
look at what's happening at an atomic
level you would see
that you have your water molecules
let me draw the water like that that is
the oxygen each of them has
two hydrogens and
this end is partially positive we've
seen this multiple times
the hydrogen end the oxygen end is
partially negative
and so when you dissolve the sodium
chloride
the chloride anions are attracted to the
positive ends of the water
so maybe you have a chloride anion there
and the sodium ions would be attracted
to the negative ends
of the h2o so that's the sodium right
over there
so when you look at it at a micro
perspective you see that there are
different molecules but in a macro
perspective the macro properties how it
responds to different stimulus how well
it conducts electricity
what it even looks like it seems to be
uniform
now to be clear salt water is not the
only liquid
solution there's many types of liquid
solutions in chemistry
we'll often see water as our most common
solvent
that's the thing that you have the most
of the thing that other things are
getting dissolved
in it the things that are getting
dissolved are called the solute in that
in this case it would be the sodium
chloride
and the water is the solvent let me
write that down
sol vent and when you have a solution
where you have something dissolved
in water this is often called an aqueous
aqueous solution
and sometimes it's abbreviated a q
now last but not least we haven't talked
about gases yet
and you can for sure have a solution of
gas and the one that's most common is
the one that you and i
are breathing right now the air around
you
is a gas solution its macro spot its
macroscopic
properties seem consistent they seem
uniform but we know that the gas
around us is a mixture of nitrogen of
oxygen of carbon dioxide as well as
molecules
of other things so a good example of a
gas solution
would be air so i'll let you go there
that's just a good primer on
what a mixture is the types of mixtures
and especially
the subtype of a mixture which is a
homogeneous mixture which we often
call a solution